his Challenger is Dr moment Oz who joins
us tonight Dr Oz thank you very much for
coming on
in the case of fetterman since he is
currently an office holder he can be
traced to very specific policies that
have increased violent crime in the
state of Pennsylvania did they not think
that anyone was going to notice that
when they put this man up for office
well it's shocking when you hear a
krasner speak there about a city he
thinks he's protecting but I've been in
Philadelphia a lot during this campaign
I live in in Philly I went to school in
West Philly and you actually talked to
the people there what they say is they
don't want to be part of a white woke
experiment a social experiment where
they're left with the consequences and
fetterman to your point said that if you
had a magic wand to do anything he
wanted to his goal would be to release
murderers from life in prison now Dr can
you imagine having a magic wand to do
anything you want I mean you could take
care of inflation although you don't
need a magic wand for that but there's
lots of things you could do but
releasing murderers from life in prison
without asking the families what they
think and oftentimes voting against the
other members of the parole board even
other Democrats is not aligned with the
values of pennsylvanians yes that's the
position he has taken
so many pennsylvanians have died of
fentanyl OD and opioid more broadly but
fentanyl I would say specifically in the
last year that it really is the numbers
are almost beyond belief and yet I don't
think stopping Fentanyl importation
dealing punishing fentanyl Peddlers is a
feature of any Democratic campaign why
is that
because they're ignoring the
humanitarian crisis they have created
with feckless policies On the Border
they've funded cartels inadvertently who
make money trafficking human beings take
the money bike fentanyl from China they
don't say anything to China about that
by the way the Fenton was brought to
America like pieces of candy and
unfortunately ends up in people's
mailboxes but fetterman goes beyond that
that's what all the Democrats do
fetterman says I want to legalize all
drugs I want heroin injection sites and
he actually embraced a measure in Oregon
which was enacted two years ago with
exactly those rules and listen carefully
this is critical 40 percent increase in
overdose death rates that's to be
expected if you legalize all drugs but
here's the part that catches me 50
increase in homicides you create a
lawless environment police aren't
allowed to do their job which is to
confiscate narcotics and this is the
world that he's trying to create for us
and by the way if you're bothered by
this and I was bothered enough to run
against them please go to doctors.com
and support me because the Democratic
party doesn't even know this about him
they're just trying to to get the 51st
senate seat so they're pouring money
into Pennsylvania so Dr oz.com at least
give me some support against them but
we're going to win on the issues just
like all the Republicans that you've
mentioned today the debate we're having
tomorrow night is going to reinforce
John fetterman's radical positions the
momentum we have is a direct response of
focusing on kitchen table issues crime
drugs we mentioned both with the border
and of course the economy everyone's
focused on although if you're in
Philadelphia right now you're worried
about your life and companies are
leaving big chains leaving the city
because they're done with the experiment
I I gotta just ask you and I I'm sure
you don't like to go to motive but it's
just it's amazing to me 107 000
Americans die of drug od's last year and
here's a guy promoting drug legalization
when we know it will result in more
deaths why would why would anyone
push an idea like that at a time like
this
because they're more concerned about the
perpetrator or the criminal than the
innocent and the victims they don't hear
the stories that I've been witnessing as
I campaign of moms telling me that
they've found their children blue and
dead because they went on Facebook and
signed up for you know a
over-the-counter pain pill and it ended
up having sex fentanyl in it we we
confiscated seven times more fentanyl in
Pennsylvania this quarter than two years
ago according to the state patrol and by
the way and all the law enforcement
groups have endorsed me because they
know fetterman doesn't have their back
and I'll fight hard to let them do their
job but Tucker that's part of the
problem when you talk to the
left-leaning politicians on the far left
especially they don't want the police to
do their jobs they don't want anyone to
do their jobs and they don't want to
therefore deal with the consequences of
it so they don't come downtown to the
prayer vigils I've attended they haven't
gone to Kensington which is the largest
open-air drug Market in the country that
we created with these bizarre beliefs
that you can give people drugs and it's
okay believe me taking heroin long term
is not a good strategy you're not going
to do well and because I know that and I
love these people and I see that the
Divine spark going out in their eyes I
want to take them to detox put them in
rehab and I'll fund that when I'm in the
Senate why wouldn't you want that and
again this is something we should all be
rooting for this should be a bipartisan
desire to make the country stable
it's really stunning to me I I and
what's social studies I think you're
going to win this senate seat in a
democratic State because of the things
you're saying right there and I and I
appreciate it Dr Oz thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight